اعتقد مالك الميليشيا فيجيني بيرجوجين من
سماهم بمعرقل الانتصار بعدم امداد قوته
بما تحتاجه من الذخيره مما يتسبب في
مضاعفه الخسائر بين مقاتله حسب تعبيره
وقال ان معرقي الانتصار يعملون بشكل مباشر
مع العدو
اعلم ان الذخائر موجوده لا يمكنني معالجه
هذه المساله رغم كثره علاقات ومعارفي
عندما نصل الى مساله التوقيع على مستندات
يهز الجميع راسه ويقول انت تعلم علاقتكم
هناك ليست بالسهله عليك ان تذهب وتعتذر
عندها يحصل مقاتلوك على الذخيره اليوم
يقتل ضعف مقاتليه فاجنر ومقاتل الوحدات
الاخرى لعدم قدره فاينر على تغطيتهم وهذا
بسبب عدم السماح بتزويدنا بما هو موجود في
المستودعات اولئك الذين يعرقلون انتصار
يعملون بشكل مباشر مع العدو
افادت مصادر طبيه اوكرانيه بمقتل سته
اشخاص في قصف صاروخي على المدينه الواقعه
جنوبيه اوكرانيا ورصد مراسل الجزيره اثار
القصف الصاروخي بعد لحظات من حدوثه واتهم
مسؤولون اوكرانيون القوه الروسيه باستهداف
احياء سكنيه في خرسون ما اسفر عن سقوط
قتلى واضرار ماديه حول هذه التطورات معنى
الان من عمان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اللواء فايز الدويري نرحب بك فايز جبهات
القتال جبهات كثيره ومتعده ومختلفه نبدا
بجبهه بخموت ما الذي يجري فيها بنظره
عسكريه واستراتيجيه
يعني الان باخذ تهاجم من ثلاث اتجاهات من
الشمال
والقوه الرئيسيه في من هذا الاتجاه هي
قوات فاقدر تهاجم من الشرق ولكنها تواجه
صعوبه
النهر في عبور النهر
ومن الجنوب والجنوب الغربي قوات مشتركه
فاقنر مع الجيش الروسي انا تاشرت في
لقاءات السابقه الى ان مستوى التنسيق ما
بين القوات الروسيه وقوات فاجنر ليست
بالمستوى المرضي لا بل يبدو ان هناك نوع
من التنافس بعد ان تحقيق انجازات من قبل
فاقنر عجز الجيش الروسي عن تحقيقها واقصد
تحديدا مدينه سوليدار بعد ذلك بدا الحديث
وتوجيه اتهامات من قبل قائد قوات فاجنر
الان هو يقدم نوع من الشكوى مظلومه عندما
يقول لا يتم تزويده بالذخيره وهذا يؤدي
الى مضاعفه الخسائر
هو يخاطب يخاطب الجيش القياده الروسية بان
الجي انا قلت ان المستوى التنسيق متدني
وهناك نوع من التنافس في تحقيق الانجازات
والادعاء بتحقيق النصر هذا ادى الى نوع من
الفجوه ما بين الشركاء في القتال وبالتالي
تقدم بما تدوا كانها مظلومه الى القياده
السياسي الروسي ان الجيش لا يقدم ما هو
مطلوب مما يؤدي الى مضاعفه الخسائر
النوع من رجل
من هذا النوع ايضا له دلالات في هذه
المرحله
نعم نعم هو هو يعكس مدى الصعوبه يعكس مدى
الخسائر سبق وتم وصفها من قبل من قبل قائد
فاجنر وغيره وصف معركه باخمت بانها مفرمه
اللحمه تم الحديث عن من قبل الجانب
الاوكراني عن قتل 1048 شخص في يوم واحد
اذا دعيني اقول قد تسقط باخمت لكن متى لا
احد يستطيع ان يحدد انما مصيرها في المدى
البعيد ما لم يتم امدادها بقوات تاتي من
الخلف قد تسقط لكن اليمن وهذا يقودنا الى
مفارقه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان الخبير
العسكري واسترتجي اللواء فايز الدواري